okay everybody it's your boy
psychobabble and we're back this time or
in Canada I think that's Russia but I
don't think any anyone knows where it is
is closest to this building
yes this one safe very simple no let's
take place looks very nice as well
okay does I don't know anything about
this game I think it is I don't know
what to survive all over it's like the
dark kind I was that game the darkness
or something we're just out tonight okay
Dorothy I'll go back now so I guess
we're in freaking mad
they're sought information for a living
yeah I guess find Canada's to say that
ever since he returned from Korea after
having served with the herbivores
he had been working as a private bath
yeah William beautiful shiny I think
let's track I've gotten in touch with
him okay
not worth hiring a private is a weakened
drive for hours and rough roads but
that's how it it always be the client
pays I get it gets it done you know I
got it oh I got a throttle okay oh all
right I guess we're doing this I'm
pretty good driver I had set up to meet
at the general store his clients
business
well actually the entire village had
mountains all over oh [ __ ] a [ __ ]
festa my god
well they shan't find I'm flying out the
red hair
anyway this game is a lot of pressure
around these parts to close the long
time but it was also fun to make more
those times entirely and right there it
never stopped
is the freaking sensitivity
right now
that's it
yeah
beyond whatever be Elizabeth alright
Carl had waited long enough for someone
to come into races and we're better get
it is a trash can you have any guts in
here from mr. battle what empty battle
look at says take that battle thank you
thank you
just checking on what's kind of here not
mind me just my daily job it's a
beautiful game boys shut shears I guess
I'm gonna open up that [ __ ] now oh [ __ ]
off and die you [ __ ] die in this game
oh I hope I see a deer in this game
that's what I really help
noise yes fun damn fire
it'll be good okay yeah
[ __ ] is that okay now I'm getting the
[ __ ] out here myself at Hamilton no
doubt new who managed the barrier Karl
wanted to give them a call but that
would have been too easy yeah exactly
boy was I Erica that's his previous life
still not a soul in sight there was no
point in waiting anymore that's Dennis
it's like the Stanley parable in episode
Hamilton is waiting for Carl in the
general store that's Dennis time for him
to get down
see if I necessary how to drive this
thing it's a beautiful car it's
maddening double didn't enjoy the lavish
country house built in the very heart
that fasiqun see the great thing is a
Canada there's no rules and outs I can
assess our lives things as fast as my
and I'm moving the region's economy
would do anything to further his fortune
but the last straw was the reopening of
a mind which gave rise to a wave of
protests and threats from the three
people
and these circumstances are working that
a good number of people must be feeling
compelled to oppose Hamilton way Bradley
fan against I'd say probably just
realistic house it for the target but
soon enough
now as you gonna tell them that wasn't
me driving they took the controls from
me otherwise I would never let that
happen
never so if you're a slider [ __ ] are you
serious een required urgent care only
[ __ ] ok this has a different game
ah they [ __ ]
well this is a different game yeah
all that [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] Canada
our starter
I got cigarettes Pinsir all right
[ __ ] outta here
is this guy's hey Dad the driver had
taken off it was still bad check it out
and leave nothing to chance
our old me to tell dr. box gonna [ __ ] is
that Bell such heart-wrenching Nordic oh
you can't pay me everything look Carl
didn't care about you about ok ok and he
got trapped
he is the first aid kits
okay this deep in the country his last
hope was to find an abandoned garage or
a farm by the roadside Harry
Wow okay
oh he's [ __ ] is a real [ __ ] game nas
was so cold already Carl did not feel
his toes anymore even better than he had
hopes Carl Faubert had succeeded once
more I am Carl father the new adventures
I need what is that have the matches and
I have fuel but I don't have what you
[ __ ] wet out here
[ __ ] I need some [ __ ] wood gonna get
what that's add how
there we go let's do this
oh yeah Donna saving a lot of good stuff
in here okay we're gone it's a next step
in the bottle it's the bottle over there
right I just gathered all the vials get
some more wood please talk now I'm gonna
start a fire out here
screen up here then I go back inside
look at that far last [ __ ] there and
[ __ ] [ __ ] up here
wait I just look real quick to see
what's around
there's something up there I know that's
where I just was okay so basically tell
me there ain't [ __ ] over here
and [ __ ] overhead yeah it's a huge
[ __ ] you think okay so here's the
plan
get his words possible I literally load
up on wood and they get the hell out of
here hey you see [ __ ] are they gone I
guess I am gold
like I got a bunch of what self
okay guys go this way
it's [ __ ] Carlton
[ __ ] the game plan
and [ __ ] out here
late chance okay keep going
madly chains I could probably back it up
that right
the friction
okay
now I can do it the other way now yeah I
can't get the [ __ ] out of here
it's [ __ ] frozen in here
got like 90 miles an hour look at my
[ __ ]
I rose any [ __ ] bears out here
[ __ ] you can see [ __ ] here [ __ ]
Donna
here
is that
a few acres of untouched forests
bellowing caribou elastic snow and under
wildlings the mana Stein region was no
tourists out it was said to have been
populated for millennia by creepy
the metal winding it
is enticing house isn't [ __ ] yes I just
[ __ ] tasarov
was running on fumes good thing that the
general store was closed behind
the general started now oh it's [ __ ]
loading hit Milo's half-life tell out
trans
yes
[Music]
okay well give it slow of guessing I
want to [ __ ]
box the milk and had to drive by every
week to fill the bottle the fresh milk
indicated their recent visit Fargo in
there I'm just gonna check everything
out so that way and often now [ __ ]
nice people this you go back outside
after okay their chair
and [ __ ] over there [ __ ] off the
tracks
karl was used to strange phenomena but a
chunk of ice like this as if an iceberg
came out of the ground that was at first
I stopped maintaining his composure Karl
recalled something from his military
training wolves always stay away from
populated areas wait is it about bears
and I mean now Nathan wasn't had a
robbery on seems like some villagers
barely tolerated each other okay
like crazy right now
and you put the camera away
break everything right
Carles long-standing and faithful ally
husbands
there's always something out there
waiting to be recognizing his employee
he had been killed there was no need to
be a detective to figure that out
but only a detective could have noticed
that the killer had to have been very
close but the fatal blow had been given
before the victim he knew this address
it was said to be the address of the PIO
box for the Canadian Secret Service
funny to draw
if I said that mass
I'll inspect that one
it's back that the bed the drink maple
sarah stairs unbranded yes something
though why go got on here why are you
just happy to see me didn't even shower
half the profits are perfecting okay
man same up same matches oh my god I
wouldn't need them for short
[Music]
liars are dumb
sector
on
I don't want Arthur
like close of that okay
an explosion suddenly occurred outside
a lot in fragile - house was in charge
of the general store that comes out of
shop filling for me very angry of what
he is Karl could plainly see
oh yeah my dad that's for sure
they can't see
okay turn off it two places the store
and the garage
the note explained that the garage and
the store couldn't be supplied with
electricity at the same time
okay well those are hot so
okay
it's a chef
yeah that's a they blew that to yourself
turned off
let's see the garage I open now
a stick yeah over there
get in there
okay
[ __ ]
okay another thing is just is on
okay so that lights went snap
what can I say
laughs our Lantern
well I don't have a there so
yeah there's expose you outside let me
just see what the hell that noise but
actually it went down
this is the generator right
9ma Wow
now is that nice
but some of the wood in there
wouldn't surrender their divine dictor's
so when I was good they had to be
switched on from the inside this door
I can't now
now with that pop was
Wow Carl was no electrician but he could
identify a wiring problem when he saw
[ __ ] tape
the general stores every tape right now
somewhere right
Hey hey where the [ __ ] is the tape
according to that raw it seemed like the
whole village owed some money to the
general store Carll was far more
interested in the bunch of nearby
address
I think that's okay
alright that's about that not too bad
Carl was no electrician but he could
identify
then pliers
I know how many [ __ ] Flyers well I
got the carrot ski now so I guess I can
go into that the other place that is
probably where the Daguerre inch part
where we get suppliers you can see the
[ __ ] how do I see their controls for
how'd I see I guess it's over there but
I wish you could [ __ ] always show
every way to see like stats
teleport
that
show tooltips enabled the navel in my
head Bob crosshair feel the video
special effect motion blur
bear why don't I marry display Oh nope
did not want to do that
did not want to do that
okay I'll back her back oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that's all [ __ ] them that's all
[ __ ] up
oh [ __ ] okay alright I got a [ __ ]
Exodus I don't know what the [ __ ] got
that's not that I [ __ ] that display
yes
I guess I'm putting it back on actually
get down I'll say that it's really good
let's launch it again
hopefully it doesn't say that guest
alright okay there we go it's beautiful
beautiful
okay a little choppy Stan I look again
prayer ball plays baby looking good I
have nothing good again this [ __ ] still
[ __ ] up
take the resolution is off Wow no wonder
the farmers auction there we go
[ __ ] the fear should be a hundred
seventy there you go get bigger okay
looks like we've finally got it oh my
god that's Gao what I don't know what
happened there I really don't know we're
gonna find out okay so here's the plan I
got the kid he got on the carriage the
character probably has deployers which
we could finally fix electricity which
means we can break down the power back
the [ __ ] for that tops [ __ ] an explosion
it's unreal crude outside according to
that log it seemed like the whole
village only chanting the General Staff
Carl was far more interested in the
bunch of nearby addresses he had just
gotten his hands on though that bad boy
lovey can't do real quick climb this
yeah no not damn that definitely pop
that side okay yeah we know it's at so
let's just run over here okay we have a
lot to this game so they say is a pacing
dark in here I know why are your pliers
[ __ ] hair pliers sir then you [ __ ]
got him in here okay I got the pliers
they came and there and [ __ ] I'll sit
here I can lay that dark when it gives a
[ __ ] every time I see that I freak out
cuz at the same time playing out of each
foot within every somebody see that I
mean someone can see you but I think in
this game means that you can see again
just well Carl was no electrician but he
could identify a wire I fixed it in like
a [ __ ] second that King turn off the
garage turn on the song right
I can't assess now
the fact
I thought can fix the liars let's just
say should be on all right there we go
okay
what the [ __ ] Garrett is off man turns
on
generator how long that's gonna be
how long it's gonna last I put her
[ __ ] Harry
come on it's time to cold out here
that's all I can say better [ __ ]
hurry Jim
I'm gonna come out it's found out you
know if I was low on gas why would I
frickin leave a thing off that was the
fastest fell with this list
all that was left to do was to sort out
the bandits and the honest citizens he
had to search the village Carl felt a
chill down his spine and had a
terrifying realization if Hamilton was
dead then who was going to pay him
you need a couple more things real quick
let me get this wine
I said let me see
jumping from that height was akin to
tempting death perhaps that man on the
snowmobile had seen enough of this world
already I'm related to know what that
key thing is bears in the brochure
next 1960
sixteen
in 1960
there's a zero
okay
they get in there
the murder weapon what happening there
Carl what Hamilton must have been
determined to keep some information
secret to post this key Jamie he got
unlucky that guy everything made sense
know where Hamilton's her uncie ation
was interrupted pause and he figured it
would be best to lock everything up and
send the key to his correspondence who
would receive the box later on clever
but not enough that's what happens to
ordinary people playing spy okay she's
gonna
miss Howe
down here
our elf elf at the store and its
surroundings still held their secrets
and he didn't like to miss out the [ __ ]
it's disgusting either you better get
the [ __ ] out of here
how big is this place oh [ __ ]
there's a lot of [ __ ] stuff here
I don't know woods I think
anything
this is hiptompaz right
[Music]
the track was fresh that meant the car
sunk down just a little while ago
now where the hell did the passengers
possible I'm so [ __ ] eridan someone
had been playing with the crossbow here
a very dangerous game a bolt could hit
someone's tire or their eye it could
even kill someone if the aim was right
okay
what chef let's understand there was
only void where the roach I related he
felt it was as if the road had grounded
I am avatars fallen satified help he put
all his [ __ ] wood
empty bottle
maybe that one really quick
oh shut okay
someone must have dropped this in a
hurry but whoever did was heading into
the woods now had that girl's tracking
instincts were quickly kicking in and
loves that here
should I be concerned
I felt engulfed by a wave of cold and
for a second thought he was fainting all
of a sudden for phantasmagoric figures
well I think that gays are do what the
hell was going on that's a really good
question
the further Carl moved away from the ice
war the more his senses came back to her
hey exact freezing
someone must have dropped this in a
hurry now but whoever did was heading
into the woods
Carl's tracking instincts were quickly
kicking in freezing
okay so just check these things okay
oh that wasn't only Shiva he was going
back to the realm of visions
I'm talkin here
dominus was giving way to awareness the
vision was wavering
I really don't know if this is a good
plan
this could be a very bad plan
it was so cold already Carl did not feel
his toes anymore
I can't get back to that [ __ ] car
well I said there's a [ __ ]
post-apocalyptic adventure game
okay
well [ __ ] the go
messing up and to the right
I can't say [ __ ] I can't see [ __ ]
I guess you got overhead out
like an aerial addict
oh [ __ ] it's called a wintry atmosphere
surrounded by the truth the soundless
nosov the area suggested it was empty
when finding a boot one wonder is what
became of the foot oh my god it's so
cozy yeah
that's why the key which seems to be
meant for a padlock or an inscription
reading higher a fish a company name
better keep an eye open businesses
weren't exactly numerous around these
parts money in a jar what a shame Carl
Buddha's cookies
[Music]
a zoom in
cigarettes just leave the cigarettes
they can't get that cigarettes
a taste for some undoubtedly harsh
lumberjack work yeah
Alexander Blair felled trees and chopped
woods for crew chief this
as that blocked off so
the spirograph amused Karl it was a nice
modern toy a site from being repetitive
by nature and completely useless still
it found its way in thank you
Bob on the cars let me get
Kyle down here that's all I gotta say
okay I think it's much wrong
closes [ __ ] phrase out Thanks
okay
yeah got some water a stake in here get
all right that French I wear to that
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
Slenderman
baseball cards
oh [ __ ] huh [ __ ] flashlight
a window left open in that weather
perhaps something had to be watched
it's diary the wish for Alexander he's
coming
okay dad so
if I can left in a rush
all had tormented I'd smack that bad you
know I agree with that body hair
something Holly [ __ ] how is that
oh [ __ ]
I don't have talking get him
now
I had a [ __ ] way to put Ross hairs on
right
is there a [ __ ] wait about crosshairs
on it
yes
do I have any [ __ ] bullets through
her temples
[ __ ]
I see close the door behind him the snow
storm pummeled everything in its path
Carl was not surprised when he heard no
tone
bob was bred out
already come up a pious and two weeks
ago engineer
I don't really know it's dying I don't
really mean to find out
okay so I want to say while you is gonna
walk out
crazy
and Atari is fall okay
before
but someone in Anna
I just have like an infinite amount
yes I go in here padlock or something
what do I have a key if it was like mozz
away
I have a [ __ ] game
all right now have a kid sick under
these things
oh my god
hatch wire
Natalia sure here
the only thing I think of is um get the
flashlight I think it's effort yeah yeah
and I couldn't see any fine
they're like infinite batteries that's
what I said I do
let's go upstairs in the flashlights
wartime you think I didn't get a super
good luck earlier that freaking think of
it they should be like here or something
I check that out I guess that's really
yet
they're a lot of hockey player magazines
okay I don't know why somebody got next
anyway you see the map well there's the
shack well which you can't go further
until
okay I forgot that
turkey friend W is castex all right
[ __ ]
and break this car
I bet Ken are they sure
right
and there should be a left around here
Meister yeah
like this music I gotta say oh I think
that thank you
not too shabby Karl felt he needed to
protect himself
it was a typical shock just like the
ones you hear about in Quebec well
legends local Lumberjacks used it to
rest and twice a day heat up their piece
ooh okay
yeah
[ __ ] my hacks to the axial wall no I
guess not
that's five anymore I'll go down to the
left
I know
[Music]
how about now where them God my guy slow
oh [ __ ] left left
[ __ ] now right all right
welcome to Ali Baba's cave lumberjack
addition surely Karl would hide
something with this time in here our
stomaches appalled okay
six matches all right
that hardware
a long talk something firestar there
a lot I got stuff in here [ __ ]
lantern holy [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] goldmine out there now
just sounds a little tear driving
I'm gonna make a [ __ ] intern here
yeah dancing
[ __ ] [ __ ]
my dad to me one mark happened down here
I said I said
turn around
[ __ ] on a table
I can find a crossbow bolts had the same
origin Karla was sure of it
who was it and more importantly what was
being hunted like this without a single
window to brighten things up the inside
of the cabin was almost pitch black
beware of close encounters of knee and
furniture yeah all right here that close
to run out of hand
solitaire a card game only permits can
truly enjoy Faro felt depressed at the
contemplated yeah
cigarettes solitaire our card game only
Hermits can truly enjoy Carl felt
depressed at the font of place a clean
glass
Heth brush everything is set up for a
well-deserved snack it seems like the
place hadn't been empty for long but
without knowing exactly why Carl had the
feeling no one was coming back anytime
soon okay
no what the [ __ ] job is by far as
everybody fire start
okay let's go back to that house with
the magnet and it was a safe right there
I'll call that we'll call that a day
let's have Mattel
go all the way down and they write [ __ ]
except the song
and pay good money first [ __ ] serious
right now
getting a house
you're right there
I can letting sliding I got so what am I
saying
I've experienced
you think there's something up there
exhale right hey let's see if we can
unlock this with the camera okay back
here we got that right let's see what to
make
saving magnet interesting okay I guess
we'll just have to wait on to the next
step but does say what's going on
anyways thanks for watching y'all that
is hakuna yeah
see you next one thank you